TOMORROW RIGHT HERE IN
WASHINGTON IN THE HOUSE.
SEAN.
>> Sean: ED HENRY IN
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR REPORT.
JOINING US NOW IS GREEN BERET
FORMER ADVISOR, MICHAEL WALTZ,
AND RETIRED CIA INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER, DANIEL HOFFMAN.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING, AND
YOU'RE THE EXPERT ON RUSSIA, THE
PRESIDENT HAD TALKED ABOUT, WE
ARE DONE IN SYRIA.
WE KNOW THAT ASSAD HAS USED
CHEMICAL WEAPONS IN THE PAST.
I DON'T THINK AMERICA CAN STAND
IDLY BY WHEN MEN, WOMEN, AND
CHILDREN ARE BEING GASSED.
THE QUESTION IS, WAS IT ASSAD
AND HIS REGIME OR POTENTIALLY
THE REBELS IN THE CIVIL WAR THAT
WANTS THE UNITED STATES TO STAY
THERE?
>> THE LINE OF THE OPPOSITION
LAUNCHING THESE ATTACKS AS A
PRETEXT OF THE UNITED STATES
COULD BECOME INVOLVED, THAT IS
THE RUSSIAN NEWS MEDIA.
AND IT'S PROPAGANDA.
THE TRUTH IS THE SYRIANS HAVE
BEEN --
>> Sean: WE KNOW THAT FOR
WE KNOW ASSAD HAS THEM.
DO THE REBELS HAVE THE WEAPONS?
>> FROM MY EXPERIENCE, IT'S BEEN
THE ASSAD REGIME THAT HAS THE
CAPABILITY TO DELIVER THE
WEAPONS.
THESE ARE BARREL BOMBS THAT YOU
NEED HELICOPTERS AND AIRCRAFT TO
DELIVER.
THE REBELS DON'T HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY.
IT'S THE ASSAD REGIME THAT HAS
THE CHLORINE AND THE SARIN GAS
TO LAUNCH THESE ATTACKS AND THEY
CONTROL THE SECURITY FOR THESE
AREAS.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO PROVE THAT ANY CHEMICAL
WEAPONS WERE USED BECAUSE
ASSAD'S OWN SECURITY GUARDS ARE
GOING TO BE SHEPHERDING AROUND
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST NEWS
REPORTS THESE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE ORGANIZATION FOR THE
PREVENTION OF CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
>> TO ADD TO THAT, WE CAN TRACK
THESE AIRCRAFT.
WE TRACKED THEM LAST TIME.
WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT AIRBASE
THEY COME FROM, AND WE KNOW THIS
IS THE ASSAD REGIME.
WE ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
INTERCEPT COMMUNICATIONS.
TO YOUR POINT, THIS PRESIDENT
UNDERSTAND TWO THINGS.
ONE, IN ACTION AS CONSEQUENCES.
AND WE ARE BEARING DOWN THE
CONSEQUENCES AND HE'S HAVING TO
DEAL WITH THE INACTION OF THE
LAST EIGHT YEARS UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA THAT'S ALLOWED
THIS PROBLEM TO GET THIS BAD.
NUMBER TWO, DIPLOMACY IS
ACTUALLY BENEFITED BY THE
CREDIBLE USE OF MILITARY FORCE.
SOMETIMES YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO
EMPLOY THAT FORCE, AND IN THIS
CASE, I HOPE AND EXPECT THAT THE
SYRIAN PILOT DOES NOT HAVE A
SINGLE RUNWAY AT LEFT AFTER THE
CRUISE MISSILES TAKE THEM OUT.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
WE CAN PARSE OUT THE ATTACK AWAY
FROM RUSSIAN ASSETS WHERE THEY
PUT VERY SOPHISTICATED RUSSIAN
ANTIMISSILE SYSTEMS AND TAKE